welcome to the show everybody on this
historic and somber day somber and
historic historic and somber some
historic day a day that is so somber and
so historic that I decided to wear my
more muted and restrained and mature
reindeer cardigan I admit I had flash
your options I could have chosen but I
decided on a day such as this I should
wear this this card he had a cardigan
that also looks a little bit like
something that a 76 year old man would
wear to the Christmas party at the elk
lodge and I even decided to place my
Santa hat tastefully off to the side
rather than wearing it on my head which
was my first option and this again is
just to is just to note to pay respects
to the historic and somber nature of
what has happened absolutely historic so
historic historic historic historic did
I mention that this is historic that's
what the media says anyway and they're
right you know it is it was a president
is impeached it's only happened a few
times and I Mary it's happened four
times in American history and so it is
historic and we're all gonna remember
where we were and what we were doing
when this when this vote was made when
this happened and I and I know that I
can tell you exactly what I was doing I
was on my couch drinking a beer watching
the Celtics play the Mavericks on ESPN
good game by the way the Celtics won 109
to 103 but that's what I was doing
because honestly I just don't care that
much about the impeachment thing I
didn't watch one second of coverage I'm
being honest wait I didn't watch one
second I don't think through this entire
thing I've watched one second of media
coverage of any of it and it's been
great it's been very liberating and
here's the dirty little secret here's
the reality that you won't hear people
in the media acknowledge because it
undermines the effort to get clicks and
hits and views and everything because
you always want to pretend in media that
everything is earth-shattering that
everything is amazing and incredible and
unprecedented and everything is a
game-changer so they're not going to
admit this but the truth is
that this whole impeachment thing will
not matter come election time it
actually won't matter that's my
prediction right now come election time
nobody's gonna care about this on either
side now I know there's there are
conservatives who are saying well this
is this just sealed the election for
Trump because there's gonna be a
backlash of voters and people are so mad
about the the impeachment it's not gonna
matter on that in it's not gonna matter
either way come election time I
guarantee you why because the election
is a year away it's almost a year 11
months and a year in modern American
culture a year in our information
saturated news saturated over stimulated
culture might as well be a decade it
might as well be a century
honestly it might as well by the time we
get to the election it this everything
that happened right now today and last
night and that's happened over the last
month or two may as well have happened
in the 18th century that's how far in
the distance it will distance it will
feel all that matters in politics
anymore is what happened like in the 12
hours leading up to people going to the
polls if people are if people are swayed
by news events at all anymore they have
to be news events from that day or the
previous day if it was a week ago it's
already a fading memory if it was a
month ago
it's teetering on irrelevance if it was
a year ago then the event has
essentially fossilized and been buried
under six miles of sediment it just it
doesn't matter now I'm not saying that
things should be like this
they shouldn't be you know we should be
able to care about things for more than
35 minutes we should be able to care
about something that happened a year ago
but we don't we just don't
so I guarantee you 11 months from now
nobody's gonna care about this no one's
gonna be talking about it no one is the
exit polls will show that nobody on
either side was voting based on
impeachment they're gonna be voting
based on something that happened that
week or more likely they're just gonna
vote based on the decision they made
that they've that they've been committed
to all along based on their party
affiliation and the tribe they belong to
that's what most people
based on so people who talk about
impeachment 11 months from now they're
gonna sound like your grandfather in his
rocking chair smoking a pipe on the
porch reminiscing fro about stories from
his childhood it will just sound it will
sound distant irrelevant and we'll all
go oh yeah yeah okay I kind of remember
that but I do have to say if there's any
if there's any big news to come out of
this impeachment it's that we need to
start teaching civics in school again I
think that's the main thing we learn
from this which isn't really news
because I think we already knew that but
I saw a lot of people in social media
last night
a lot of people who seem to be under the
impression that Trump is now kicked out
of office just because he was impeached
there was a lot of yay we're free of
Trump football spiking going on which is
kind of like a receiver breaking free on
a long pass but then stopping at the
25-yard line and spiking the football in
celebration you know you're not they're
not in the end zone yet and in this case
there's a big wall in front of the end
zone and you're never gonna get in
because Trump is not gonna get kicked
out of office it ain't gonna happen he's
not gonna get convicted in the Senate
that's just simply not gonna happen and
which is another reason yet again why
this story is not gonna matter eleven
months from now as soon as the trial and
whatever whatever whatever end ups ends
up happening in the Senate as soon as
that happens no one's gonna care any
more about this we're all gonna move on
from this so quickly all right um and so
I'm going to as well and let's let's
let's move on before we do that a word
from quip quit the makers of the equip
electric toothbrush want you to know
that the one single discovery that makes
most of your that matters the most for
your dental care is simply this that if
you have good habits you're good it's as
simple as that
that means brushing for two minutes
twice a day flossing regularly no matter
what brand you use you know the main
thing is just developing those habits
quick makes that simple starting with an
electric toothbrush refillable floss and
an anti cavity toothpaste equips
electric brush has sensitive sonic
vibrations with a built-in timer and
30-second pulses to guide a full and
even clean and again this is all about
developing those good or
hygiene habits the quit floss dispenser
comes with pre-marked string to help you
use just enough plus quick delivers
fresh brush heads floss a toothpaste
refills to your door every three months
so it keeps you in that routine you're
not breaking the routine and you keep
that habit going join the over three
million healthy mouths that get clipped
today starting at $25 $25 that's it and
if you get if you go to get quit dot-com
slash Walsh right now you'll get your
first refill for free
that's your first refill free at get
quip dot-com slash Walsh spelled GE T Q
u IP comm / Walsh quit the good habits
company alright
comedian Michelle wolf you may remember
her well probably you don't actually
I'll refresh your memories she was that
lady at the White House Correspondents
Dinner a year ago who gave a super
cringy unbearably unfunny performance
and everyone everyone on the Left
pretended it was funny like they do a
lot with especially especially FEMA with
liberal female comedians like Samantha
bee and this woman and so many others we
have to deal with people on the Left
pretending that these people are funny
and have wit when they're not funny and
they have no wit whatsoever but she's a
she's one of those comedians who tries
to compensate for the lack of wit by
going for the shock factor which is yet
again a common flaw among liberal female
comedians where they they have no
punchlines they have no jokes so they
just try to shock you and then the whole
joke is well did you hear that did you
hear the inappropriate thing that that
that lady said that's the whole joke
that's the whole Act case in point in
her recent Netflix comedy special she
goes into a rant about her abortion a
rant that is pathetic gross sad but
completely forgets to check the funny
box watch for yourself we talk about
abortion in a real way you talk about it
in a very legislative way but not
so I think a lot of women have a lot of
apprehension surrounding it you know we
talked about so negatively that you feel
like you should have this sense of shame
after you get an abortion well you can
feel any way you want
after you get an abortion get one see
how you feel you know my abortion made
me feel very powerful you know people
say you can't play God
[Applause]
Morgan Freeman and then I crossed the
street very carefully first of all can
you imagine sitting in an auditorium for
an hour and listening to that my god the
voice the delivery its grating its it's
leaving aside the content for a moment
everything else is torturous it is I
mean you look up shrill in a dictionary
and that's annual and this is when you
find that well you'd what I just played
for you oh my god Michelle wolf is is I
double take this she's not doing female
comedians any favors I could tell you
that she certainly isn't breaking down
or dispelling the stereotype about women
not being funny and when you think about
it Netflix comedy specials I think about
Netflix comedy specials this year you
had Bill burr and Dave Chappelle which
were which brilliant a lot of really
funny smart material actual jokes if you
can imagine in the in the comedy special
things to laugh about and then and then
and then you have this ouch
female comedians when they when they go
to Netflix they're not sending their
best
I guess Trump might say at any rate as
for the joke itself if that's what it is
I want to be clear about something my
reaction to this and I think the
reaction of every pro-lifers any
pro-lifer I've seen so far reacting to
it it's not a reaction of outrage I'm
not not mad about this we're not foaming
at the mouth and anger the way some left
us on Twitter were when Neil Gorsuch
said Merry Christmas on Fox and Friends
oh there was some foaming at the mouth
anger going on there that's that's not
we're doing our overwhelming feeling
with this kind of thing is one of
sadness it's sad to see a woman who
murdered her child tried so desperately
to rationalize and justify it that way
she's lying to herself and she's lying
to us and we all know it I can guarantee
you she did not come out of that
abortion she didn't leave that facility
feeling like a God feeling powerful
that's not how she felt
here's the thing here's the really
important point if a woman feels
powerful maybe not like a god we'll get
to that a minute but if a woman feels
powerful confident in charge
that woman is is not going to get an
abortion she's not getting hurt she's
not going to have her child killed
because that woman is going to be
excited about her baby in about the
future and confident in her ability to
have a baby and still pursue her dreams
and have a career that's why confident
powerful woman that's how she's going to
approach a pregnancy know what drives
women to the abortion clinic and the
feeling that the clinic tries to
inculcate the feeling they try to they
go out of their way to create and stir
up within within the women who come is
one of fear and helplessness and
desperation now you go to a pregnancy
center a pro-life pregnancy center and
the message there is gonna be you can do
this you got this we'll help you we're
here for you don't be afraid that's the
message from the pro-life Pregnancy
Center the message from the clinic is be
afraid be very afraid your life is over
unless you kill the child it's a choice
between your life or your child's you
can't do both you just can't you don't
have it in you you got to kill you got
to kill the child you have you have you
have to choose but you really have no
choice you got to kill a child so a
woman leaves that feeling empowered I
mean this is how confident okay this is
how this is how much confidence really
the the clinic wants the women have when
when the women are walking into the
clinic if a sidewalk counselor tries to
approach them and just hand them
literature I mean they said the clinic
sends people out often men as like
bodyguards okay not because these
woman's not because the women they're
their safety is being threatened in any
way not not at all no it's just to
protect to protect them from being given
literature to protect them from being
spoken to and told about their other
options is that
finance is that power do you have to
protect a powerful and confident woman
from being handed a brochure with
information on it information about her
own pregnancy and what's going on
biologically no there's no power and
it's all about breaking the woman down
and she leaves broken
she's broken and now she's guilt-ridden
and that's how she leaves that's the
state the clinic leaves her in and
leaves her - it leaves her to a life of
brokenness and guilt doesn't care they
have once they get what they want out of
you which is the four hundred bucks for
killing the baby that's it they're done
with you
it's transactional they don't care
that's the other thing by the way
speaking of you know paying $400 or
whatever the price is gonna be what's
empowering about a woman paying a man
400 bucks to go inside her body and kill
her baby what's empowering about that
keep in mind very often these abortion
quote-unquote doctors are men yet she
says Michelle wolf says she felt like a
god she was playing God well that part
is true you know as to that part I
believe her and there's a paradox here
though isn't there because I'm saying
she was playing God yeah but but I don't
think she really felt powerful that only
seems like a paradox if you know that
may seem like a paradox but really it
makes a lot of sense because we are not
gods we cannot be gods
so our attempt to play God will fail and
we'll be left feeling even more
powerless than we did before
so to be more specific Michelle wolf
felt like a failed God a God who in the
end actually forfeited the most profound
power that she had because think about
that killing someone you say you felt
powerful because he killed someone kill
anyone can kill somebody especially a
baby
what's powerful about killing a baby the
most helpless innocent defenseless being
on the planet and you killed them
power does it doesn't take
power anyone can do that now when I say
it's easy it's not easy to do morally or
emotionally if you're a decent human
being in fact if you're a decent human
being
it's impossible to do but if you're a
morally bankrupt self-absorbed
cold-blooded narcissist like Michelle
wolf then sure yeah murder is easy no
problem there's no power in it though
creating life
okay bringing life into the world now I
mean that is power there is in fact
almost something like a godlike power in
it a god-like power that God gives to us
the power to make life think about that
what is more powerful man to create life
to Harbor that life in your body and
then bring that life out into the open
wide world now that's that's power and
what women are told is by rejecting that
profound amazing power a power that only
women have now men do of course help in
creating the life if they have a 50/50
role there but in terms of women have it
obviously a unique and powerful role in
that process that that men don't have
and so the left says by rejecting that
power you a woman is powerful by doing
the thing that anyone can do by doing
the thing
any murderous selfish person can do it
just kill somebody a baby that's what
makes you powerful no not at all
all right um I wanted to tell you we've
got a couple days left before before the
holidays before the before Christmas
kicks off in earnest and this holiday
season you could do your friends and
family a solid by getting them a daily
wired gift membership and the good news
for you from now till January 1st all
insider plus gift memberships will be
25% off that means your loved one will
get all the fantastic perks plus the
majestic leftist ears tumblr and you'll
get all the savings that's 25% off all
insider plus gift memberships this
holiday season go to daily wire comm
slash gift to get your 25% off again
that's daily wire comm slash gift to get
your 25% off give them a gift but
they'll thank you for all year long by
the way wanted to get into emails here
in a second but the reviews for this new
Star Wars movie have come out and right
now last I checked on Rotten Tomatoes I
think it's got like a 58% which is bad
Rotten according to Rotten Tomatoes and
so it's just it's just being abysmal II
rated I think it's gonna end up being
perhaps the worst rated reviewed Star
Wars movie yet and even even worse than
Phantom Menace which was a which was an
abomination in so many ways as most
people know but this should not be
surprising I think what we're learning
here is that you know there's oh there's
only so much story to be told so this is
what the 9th Star Wars movie and it's
not even care I'm not even counting all
the other peripheral things and the
offshoots and the other spin-offs and
the TV shows so there's even more than
that but just in the in the primary film
franchise we're now on the right 9th
movie right and if they're each about
two hours long on average let's say so
you're talking about 18 hours 18 hours
is there really
18 hours worth of story to be told based
on this you think about that first Star
Wars movie which I have to tell you and
look this is not me I'm not I'm honestly
not trying to be contrarian when I say
this I am guilty sometimes with being
contrarian I admit but this is not it
an attempt at a contrarian take I'm
telling you if you watch that first Star
Wars movie new hope the I mean
chronologically at least in terms of
when they were produced the first one
although I know it's really episode four
in the in the storyline but if you watch
that one and without without the
nostalgic attachment now I know that if
you saw at first when you were a kid and
you've grown up with Star Wars then you
you're not capable of looking at these
things objectively because of your
nostalgic attachment to them and I
understand that I don't begrudge you
that but I had I guess a strange
childhood because I never saw Star Wars
growing up as a kid I just never I had
no interest in it I could have watched
it but I didn't I wasn't interested in
it so I watched when I was adult an
adult i watch Star Wars for the first
time starting with new hope the first
one made and it is really not a good
movie it honestly isn't if you go in if
you go in cold
you have no attachment to the movie
you're not rooting against it you don't
dislike it without you just you're just
you're like okay let me let me turn on
this movie if you look at it like that
it's really not that good the acting is
bad if Mark Hamill is not a good actor
especially in that movie maybe gets a
little better as a series goes on but he
is not good in that movie so it is it is
like d-list level acting the script is
not good the dialogue is clunky and it's
kind of campy and kind of fun I guess
but it's not my point is it's really not
a great film and then you have to look
at that and ask yourself it is so based
on that first movie is there 18 hours
worth of material to be mined from that
it's it's not that inventive ok George
Lucas didn't really come up this we
didn't you didn't invent this idea of a
space opera it is it's it's actually
pretty derivative in parts so I don't
know I I think that's what we learned
that you even even you see all these
movie franchises that go on forever and
ever
ever even a great film okay even a
really really great film which with with
with that is complex and dense and with
great characters and everything you're
probably not gonna find 18 hours where
the material from it but the first stars
movie isn't even that great and it just
goes on and on and on which is why each
it which is why each new Star Wars movie
it just repeats just over Africa it's
the same story repeated over and over
and over and over and over again yeah
the the special effects get a little
better each time but that's it how many
times do I have to see the same story
and what annoys me about it is that
while the Star Wars universe I don't
think has enough in it to justify 18
hours of story
the Star Wars universe doesn't but the
the actual universe does what I mean is
look if you want to if you want to make
a movie a sci-fi movie about things
happening in space where involves aliens
and spaceships and adventures I say
great do that that's fantastic there's
it and and and literally endless
possibilities for telling stories set in
space but all of the all of our all the
resources in Hollywood everything is
focused on wealth we're gonna tell a
space story it has to be Star Wars
that's what annoys me it's like just can
we get away from the Star Wars thing and
if we have we have filmmakers and and
and and script writers and actors who
want to you know be in a do a movie
about space just let them do that which
it doesn't need to be Star Wars can we
just put that aside if I we've done Star
Wars we get it and let's just let's just
move on there's there's old there's a
lot of space left in space for other
stories it's the same thing with all
these Marvel movies and Avengers it's
like if you want to tell a story about
someone with supernatural powers there's
there's a lot you could do
with that a lot of really interesting
stories you could tell it doesn't have
to be it doesn't have to involve
spider-man or Ironman like we we
understand we've seen those stores we've
seen everything those guys can do we get
it create a new character with
supernatural abilities have them do
something completely different all right
but I know the movie will make a billion
dollars on its first weekend for some
reason at this point at this point
you've seen you've seen 16 hours of Star
Wars like people are just itching I
gotta go I gotta go see it again I've
seen the same movie eight times already
I know I gotta go I gotta go on opening
weekend to watch it again one more time
I was gonna I'm gonna hand my money over
to Disney they have no respect for me as
a as a fan as a viewer because they're
just they're just they're just shoving
tripe into my mouth just garbage no
respect for me they're not even trying
to make an original story
it's just reheated leftovers it's like
going to a restaurant and you know that
they're serving you the leftovers from
the previous night microwaved and you go
and you give them their money and they
literally shovel it into your mouth I
mean who would do that yeah this is what
we do with Hollywood I don't understand
it all right let's go to emails Matt
Walsh show at gmail.com Matt Walsh show
at gmail.com from Patrick says hello
Matt I was having a conversation with a
friend and I was wondering where you
stood on a particular issue do you think
gambling is a sin obviously people can
become addicted to gambling it can ruin
lives but that is also true with alcohol
and in moderation there's nothing wrong
with a couple beers you have any prop
further opinion on the matter is playing
poker every couple weeks totally
acceptable yeah it's totally acceptable
as long as you aren't wagering your life
savings or something I can't see how
putting down a little bit of money in a
poker game every once awhile could it
all be considered an act of evil provide
again that it's your money and it's not
too much of it now certainly anyone who
takes the position or I know that some
people do take the position that all
gambling is sinful but if you take that
position you must realize that rules out
the lottery obviously bingo night okay
the stock market and many other things
many things fall
to the realm of gambling gambling is a
game of chance where you could win money
and and that encompasses a lot of stuff
I don't see how it could be considered
intrinsically immoral to do it why would
it be who cares now maybe you could
argue that it's a waste of money it's a
frivolous use of money but so is going
to the movies so it's buying tickets to
Disney World so is many other things
many things it's it's a form of
entertainment so if you've if you've
spent money on entertainment and it may
it might not count as gambling but I
don't see the difference
so I say don't worry about it
gamble away well don't gamble away I
mean you get my point that's that in the
gamble away with the opposite of the
point I was trying to make but you know
anyway moving on you get it this is from
beb's says Matt I agree with your stance
on pornography but how can you fail to
see how it applies to alcohol tabacco
those things are just as bad as porn you
defend alcohol tabacco constantly on
your show especially on wednesdays show
which I found very disappointing Bev I
don't know if it's true that I defend
alcohol tabacco constantly on my show I
am fans of both I admit so maybe I do I
don't know you say they're as bad as
porn do you really think that though is
that really so let me ask you a married
man
imagine a married man who drinks a
bottle of beer every night just one
bottle with dinner very normal a lot of
a lot of people do now imagine a man who
watches hardcore porn every night you're
telling me that those are morally equal
that those two guys are in the same
moral state and that if you were the the
wife you know if you if you're the wife
in that scenario you would have no
preference between the two you would be
just as offended and upset and troubled
if your husband had a glass of beer with
dinner as you would be if he after
dinner every night went up to his to his
room on his laptop watch porn I it's
hard for me to believe you really see it
that way maybe you do now I'm not gonna
take this in a theological direction but
if you're a Christian I should mention
and I don't know if you are or not but
that that if you are
your view on this I have to say is
totally untenable theologically Jesus
Jesus Christ drank alcohol he provided
alcohol to a party as his first miracle
on earth please don't give me any stuff
about how it was not non-alcoholic that
is nonsense it's suffering that is total
nonsense there is no interpretation or
translation of that story that it all
supports that assumption it was
alcoholic wine it even says so in the
passage it says so in effect where the
the partygoers the attendees of the
wedding were marked on how this was the
finest wine they'd had so far and
usually now they say usually you serve
you know you serve the good stuff first
and then you serve the bad stuff well
why do you serve the bad stuff later
because people have already had the good
stuff and they're feeling good
ie a little tipsy and and then that's
when you throw the bad stuff what the
people were marking on is well now you
just serve the finest wine later clearly
indicating that this is alcoholic wine
when you talk about the finest or best
wine you're not talking about grape
juice now this is it this is really
important this actually this way you
know Christians who if you're
uncomfortable with alcohol if you don't
want to be around it as a personal
preference totally fine I understand I
mean I have no issue with that but to
take the position that it's
intrinsically immoral or evil in any
dosage similar to pornography or as bad
as or worse how could you possibly take
that view if you are in fact a Christian
it makes no sense because then you're
accusing Jesus of engaging in
intrinsically immoral activity and and
it's and you're also accusing him of the
sin of scandal for providing it so what
you're saying is that Jesus in providing
wine it would be the same as if you
provided pornography to the wedding
guests okay but putting that to the side
because I don't even know if you're a
Christian I just wanted to say that for
the record
what makes alcohol immoral in and of
itself
I say porn is immoral in any dose in any
amount and harmful in any amount and I
say this because it is by definition the
commodification of sex it is sex reduced
to spectacle it is the degradation of
women for the pleasure of men and
sometimes a degradation of men for the
pleasure of women it is debased and
perverse again by its very nature by
definition
studies show that any amount of exposure
any amount has a traumatic effect on
children and psychologically damages
them and all porn again in any amount
has a profoundly negative effect on
everybody on families on men on women on
marriages porn has no positive
application no neutral application it is
only harmful and that's what pornography
is now let's talk about alcohol let's
take a very common scenario the one that
I just the one that I just mentioned
very common case is not some far-fetched
thing someone who has a glass of beer
once a night or a couple few times a
week or whatever there's most people who
drink that's how they drink most people
aren't binge drinkers so um what about a
guy in that situation he's having the
beer it's not damaging him physically
it's not the amount of alcohol that
amount of alcohol for a grown man who is
in good health is not damaging he could
do that his whole life and suffered no
serious side effects at all
now most research suggests that two
drinks a night for a man two drinks is
moderate that's that's what that's what
most of the medical advice now is that's
what most doctors will tell you that if
you drink if you're a man grown man
healthy you have two drinks a night
that's considered moderate and there's
not gonna be any significant harm done
to you I'm not aware of any research
that suggests that one or two drinks a
night for a man would have significant
damaging effects on his health I'm not
aware of any study that says that so in
moderate consumption it isn't harmful it
may actually carry some benefits
now that's controversial but and it's
sort of beside the point but the fact is
it could possibly have some positive
benefit we don't even heed to talk about
though the fact is it has no negative
side effect in moderation it also isn't
intoxicating so your health is not
impaired your
mind is not impaired your judgment is
not impaired what's the problem
I mean what's what's the argument
exactly in this scenario what how is it
evil but why because it could be harmful
if you drank it too much well yeah but
anything can be harmful if you consume
too much of it water can kill you if you
drink too much of it so that can't
possibly be the reason just because
something can be harmful in in in a
moderate dosages doesn't mean that it's
automatically wrong in moderate dosages
right obviously so then what is it you
could say well a lot of people do
struggle with alcoholism
yeah that's an argument for not drinking
around people who struggle with
alcoholism but if you're by yourself and
there's no one around who struggles with
alcoholism and it's not hurting you and
it's not intoxicating you and it has no
no significant health drawbacks with
what does it matter who cares I've
explained now multiple times
why porn in any dosage is harmful I know
and no one has has so far explained why
that should have applied alcohol a lot
of people have said oh it's the same as
alcohol I mean you can assert that but
no-one's explained how it is I think
I've now multiple times explained how it
definitely is not the same you may
personally dislike it that's fine but I
you need to give me an argument for why
a man drinking one beer at night by
himself is doing something wrong yes
that's the argument I want to hear okay
let's see what else
this is from Griffin says hello Matt my
fiancee 25 and i-21 are getting married
in January she has an 8 year old son
we're also in the process of buying a
house together we're thrilled but also
apprehensive because it's a bit of a
leap of faith financially I have one
year of school left before I get an
engineering degree from a respected and
demanding school my fiance makes a good
outwardly wage but for the first year of
our marriage she will have to be the
provider financially as I won't be able
to contribute a whole lot because of the
commitment that my school will require
my question to you is this would it be
morally wrong for us to apply to receive
food stamps while I'm finishing school
with the new mortgage utilities and the
like we will be under a lot of stress
money-wise until I'm done with school it
can enter the working world that's not
to say that we won't be able to feed
ourselves and my soon-to-be stepson but
there's no doubt that monthly food
stamps would ease the burden and allow
us a bit more freedom to save for the
future and pay off minor outstanding
debts that we have can i in good
conscience call myself a conservative if
I'm getting food stamps well Griffin you
asked for my opinion so I'll give it
whether you can call yourself a
conservative or not I who cares that I
don't even know what that word means
anymore nobody does so who cares about
that but is it the right thing to do
well I would say I would say in your
case no now I can only go based on the
description of the situation that you
provided and you say you can afford food
you you seem to indicate you could
afford it rather easily
but using food stamps would give you
more financial freedom and it would
allow you to save some money and also
pay off your debts I mean the problem is
anyone could justify food stamps on that
basis it would give anyone financial
freedom
it would allow anyone more more of an
ability to pay off debts and save some
money I just think that food stamps is
supposed to be for people who can't
afford food that's mine now I know
that's not how it's used but you asked
for my opinion and so I'm giving you my
opinion is that if you can afford food
you should be on food stamps if you
can't then that's it's there for you
that's how it should be used but you
have to follow your own conscience and
perhaps you pray it's quite possible
your actual situation is more dire than
it comes to
cross in your email maybe you were being
more reserved and described it so I
don't know so who really cares what I
have to say you have to do what you
think is right I think the fact that
you're questioning it like this and you
feel the need to ask the question might
again be an indication that you know you
know it's a little iffy so I don't know
but that's that's just that's my well
that's my own personal feeling about it
let's see from Lucas says hi Matt
philosophical question for you is
morality innate or is it the result of
cultural conditioning if so why do we
see differences in moral systems across
the world yeah I think it's an eight
there's there's there's a lot of
evidence for that but let me just
mention let me mention just one one
piece of evidence that I think is pretty
interesting and and that is that people
we talk about morality being an eight
well we know that in part because people
are able to make instant and intricate
moral distinctions without even thinking
about it okay so one example in John the
writer Jonathan Hite talks about this in
one of his books and I was reading
another book recently that mentions is
this example I can't remember the name
of the book but if I think of it I'll
say it anyway the example touches on the
the trolley problem which I've mentioned
before on this show and the truck the
trolley problem asks what you would do
if you saw a trolley headed towards a
group of five people on the tracks and
there's a switch you can flip if you
flip it the trolley will change tracks
and but there's one there's one guy
walking on the other track so if you
flip the switch the trolley will go that
way and hit the one guy rather than the
five and so the thought experiment is
would you flip the switch
now most people you ask and they've done
surveys and studies with this and most
people say yeah I'd flip the switch
because you know it better to save the
five now here's another scenario trolley
on the tracks five people on the tracks
but there's no switch instead
you're standing on a bridge overlooking
the scene and that guy who was on the
track well now he's actually up standing
next to you and so you could push him
onto the tracks and thereby stop the
trolley but kill him in the process now
in that case would you push him
most people say no okay now the effect
is the same in both cases one man dies
instead of five so you could say for all
intents and purposes it comes down to it
it's the same thing the guy's dead
either way
yet most people you talk to say I would
flip the switch I wouldn't push the man
why is that well I think the difference
is so innately obvious to us that we
don't appreciate how interesting it is
that people can make that distinction so
easily
a computer program program couldn't make
it if you fed that problem into a
computer program the computer program
program is going to tell you it's the
same because a computer isn't going to
recognize any moral distinction between
those two things all the computer is
looking at is the is the result but and
the computer is gonna say well you know
push push him or pull the switch he's
dead either way
you save the five who cares so um you
can't ask someone that question you
could try this yourself ask someone
about those scenarios get their answer
and then ask them why they answered that
way and they probably can't tell you why
even though they answer confidently and
the answer almost automatically and I
think the answer correctly a lot of
people when you ask them why they would
they'd struggle to explain even though
they're right so what's happening here
well the philosophical distinction has
to do with the principle of double
effect which states that you can do a
good act with a good effect with a good
effect
intended even if a bad thing will also
happen as a result as long as that bad
thing is not being done as a means to
the good so it's a difference between
double effect and ends justify the means
double effect you can do it and justify
the means you can't morally pulling the
lever is double effect good at pulling
the lever good intent saving the five
people killing the man is not the means
to that effect it's just it's a it's a
sort of side effect it's a it's it's a
it's an unintended and tragic
unfortunate although foreseen result but
pushing the man onto the track is a bad
act because you push them and you're
merging and it's a it is the means by
which you save the five so that's wrong
now here's my point and this is
fascinating when you think about it most
people can automatically without even
thinking and without knowing that
they're doing it and without being able
to explain it after the fact most people
can identify even like a ten year old
can identify this very fine delicate
philosophical distinction between double
effect and ends justify the means that
is really fascinating when you think
about it it's that because when you when
you really stop and consider it and
contemplate it it's a difficult thought
experiment now how is it how are we able
to reflexively and instantaneously make
correct and profound moral distinctions
that we can't even explain I would say
it's because it's an eight you know it's
almost for the same reason that our
livers can function even when we even if
we can't explain how our liver functions
and if we're not conscious of it
functioning it still does it now it's
not exactly the same thing but a similar
sort of you know the way that we morally
recognize these these distinctions is is
is almost instinctive in that kind of
way
which tells me I just I don't think
something like cultural conditioning can
explain that
because I don't actually don't think the
culture does conditioned us to recognize
the difference between double effect and
ends justify the means
in fact the culture even I think the
culture especially these days militates
against this innate moral understanding
so if you answer correctly on that
thought experiment identifying even if
you don't know what the difference
between ends justify the means and
double effect you are doing it
despite actually I would say your
cultural conditioning not because of it
so that's one of the reasons why I think
morality is innate but we could talk
about it for three more hours which I
won't do because we're gonna leave it
there
thanks everybody for watching thanks for
listening on this historic and somber
day Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey supervising
producer Mathis Glover supervising
producer Robert Stirling technical
producer Austin Stephens editor Donovan
Fowler audio mixer Mike Cora Mina the
Matt Walsh show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19
Democrats impeach President Trump as
Alyssa Milano leads a rally chant that
this is what democracy looks like we
examine what happens now we remember
what the founders thought about
democracy because if this is what
democracy looks like I'm out check it
out on the Michael Noel's show